street fighter 5 still has some work to  do but it does look really pretty and if  you're not a fan of the anime look then  maybe you'd be interested in what the  game originally looked like producer ke  Chi sugiyama said street fighter 5  originally had a photorealistic look the  art style was short-lived but there is  some surviving concept art and a  screenshot you can see a very different  looking ryu and m bison the look was  changed because the team felt it looked  too much like Virtua Fighter instead of  Street Fighter the one holdover from  this style is the bearded ryu costume  you may know him as hot ryu so that  should make some of you pretty happy  street fighter 5 released on februari  16th and we're still waiting on proper  story and arcade modes at least the  game's connectivity issues have been  mostly fixed if capcom has more to say  about the future or past of the series  you'll hear about it from gamespot